all she's got is me
she's coming home
[Music]
you started this
first Rambo was 1982 37 years ago so if
I had said to you if somebody had said
to you in 1982 it's gonna be one of the
longest-running franchises in history
what was your reaction not as impossible
because no one even wanted the first one
I was the 11th choice and I basically
had to do a song and dance to get a
distributor so it was always a very
remote character an isolated character
kind of like it what he was so the fact
that we're here today it's a modern
miracle cinematic did anybody ever tell
you cuz you know you said so many actors
turned down the role has anybody ever
come to you there's always look at the
famous I wish I hadn't turned that down
who came to you and said I wish I never
turned out Rambo well it was actually it
was the director and you know everyone
else is kind of like you know actors to
go I didn't want it anyway better
actually one actor came up to me I think
was John Savage or something like that
and he was already fella from midnight
right he goes I would have played it
naked oh my gosh that's what the story I
heard that he was the play which is that
we know those branches are bad they were
you right
the thing is the character was so savage
in the beginning right that he was Nick
so it makes make sense oh yeah no it
wasn't like I was being like making fun
of him he was as primitive and fearow
you get right and that's why he had to
be killed
speaking of savage you put on your
Instagram recently John's mancave cuz
you have quite an elaborate mancave in
this film I know you live with a lot of
women do you have a man cave and where
do you go when you need to have that
time well my man cave has been invaded
by female bear caves so I thought I had
one so now I all I have is my office
what's the China like the ego room
because every now you know so much
memorabilia and I put it around the
house you guys you know everything's
about you
so yeah so I everything is been shoved
in my office so you go in there and it's
actually overload or bobbleheads
the Oscars are there everything is there
everything that's the place you go if
I'm talking about when you're talking
about nostalgia and everything that's in
your office
cuz I think you posted something
recently - it was your greatest hits but
it was kind of a spoof what is your
greatest hit what do you think your
greatest hit is film wise a moment a
scene a character oh boy I said you know
some of my losers have like fists I
thought was a really good film I thought
that Nighthawks is great movie and
eventually I think they're gonna make it
now is the series that that bothered me
I thought Copland
Coppola should have deserved a better
fate but they release it during this
summer and I thought really not a summer
movie but yeah yeah and I love working
with Kurt Russell that was a favor well
I was gonna ask you because you've now
brought us Rambo back after almost or a
little over ten years you gave us rocky
recently congratulations on all their
awards with Creed is there another
character that you would like to bring
back I vote further over the top I would
loved that movie
is there a character you'd like to bring
ice well if you're gonna do it there is
I'm talking with Robert Rodriguez right
now I hope he doesn't mind about Cobra
which looks like that can happen as a
series so you know it's basically his
baby now right I would do Tango in cash
in a second because I know with Curt
it's not about you know really a caper
it's just us yeah and he goes I don't
know it's like there we are in our prime
and now we're like in our unprimed and I
don't know
I think Curt I'm telling you you got it
going on but I'll talk to you when I get
back guardians and I know James has said
he wants you back for guardians like a
bigger role is that gonna happen or yeah
I really
James is a man of his word so if he
whatever he wants I love James okay if
he wants to do it
I've lived in a world of death
I've watched people I've loved I
[Music]
so first was a boy
some not enough left to bury for both of
you even though this is an action movie
and sly is known for action movies for
the both of you was very dramatic
material and I actually just slide which
is sort of telling me that it was one of
those movies that he's like how far do
we go how far do we push things and I
think you really went there so if you
could talk a little bit about that yeah
sure so I feel like this Rambo although
all the previous Rambo's have been about
war but I feel like this one is a little
more intimate because it does touch on
family he's never had a family before
and and this is the first time he gets
to go back home to his ranch live a
simple life and then boom I end up
rebelling and going to Mexico and the
war starts again you know he has to go
and protect his family so and I do love
that it sheds light on the sex
trafficking although Rambo's and all
about it it sheds light on it and I feel
like that was super important because
it's a big problem in America everywhere
actually yes and this film the
opportunity to the audience to see a
human being it's unique yeah because
it's not only an action figure an action
icon it way the audience can see the
human being with or without age with a
broken soul and I think the audience can
embrace and I think people love
Sylvester Stallone is because yeah well
one thing that was nice about this is
like you said you don't often see him
talking a lot in films and this was the
most dialogue he's ever had in a Rambo
yeah and so for the two of you because
you two had the bulk of your scenes with
him having that conversation was was
there over the first moment like was it
kind of like oh my gosh it's a legend
it's why well my first moment was
actually an action scene you saw the
movie right yeah when he goes and picks
me up to save me
oh my god yeah that was my first thing
you know
I was really nervous when I was glad as
an action scene because it got it was I
was able to see him and just get used to
him and his his aura and just how he was
and talked to him more because I was
really nervous at first I mean this is a
big franchise and you know he's rocking
I'm glad the action stuff happened first
but he he definitely had my back and and
wanted me to do my best work so he he
laid it out there like you know I'm your
friend we are good yes sir yeah nice my
first thing was when when he is with a
course and I saw oh my god
he is not only a natural and and this
kind of icon an actor he's a wonderful
writer with the horse yes yeah really a
writer and it was so beautiful the time
obviously I was excited yeah because I
will I will
acting with Sylvester Stallone II and
for the first time we connect at the
beginning it was easy and beautiful yeah
favorite movie favorite movie because I
know he his daughters were asked with
their favorite and they said Creed and I
think it's funny because it's more of
like for a younger generation yeah yeah
you have a favorite if Copeland he said
that was one of his first eyes
yeah I really really loved Rocky
one he talked so much about it I mean
it's funny because I watched it on the
plane right there when I was about two
two and then I brought it up to him and
he gave me so much details about behind
the scenes I don't know if you remember
that that one scene where he was on on
the roller rink with Adrian and it
popped his finger out and and then he
popped it back in that was actually real
there's so many details I was like what
so I love rocky one and last question I
know he is a man cave in this and you
know how guys like have their man yeah
Eve so I'm gonna ask you ladies when you
need to escape and escape the business
and that where's worse your place that
you go hmm I like to I don't know it's
kind of tough because I have so many
places like I live right next to the
beach so I like to go to the beach I
like to hike a little bit or I like to
go to we work
yeah Mountains are like mountains I love
cold because I born in a cold place and
twists I love wood
[Music]
so now we have the family all together
was this what it was like there's a lot
of joking around here's something about
a secret handshake no it was like this
or ever would have hung them so we got
along great but obviously this is kind
of a testament to act because you you
turn it on when you have to and
afterwards people are like plenty this
is the way it is and usually in dramatic
films people say it's the funniest onset
so there's a line in the movie there's
there's a time that you two are having
this conversation where you say I don't
know what I want to do and you say as
John Rambo I always wanted to be a
soldier right so I wanted to ask the
three of you is this always what you
wanted to do
no really no I wanted to do a ballerina
oh but I cannot by do you know I never
turned anybody could and then I have to
tweak a tomar una clase is Pacifica in
solo era basketball day at Rome Egypt
well theater she had to take a specific
class theater basketball and Dana
discovered theater at my six things you
know and I was really happy because I
know this is my place
yeah that's right I ordered the trained
horses that was it and that's why I've
tried to put it in as much as possible
yeah I love them I just that that was my
calling
I said mm-hmm and I actually auditioned
for a play to get out of doing sports
believe in the Sun Hat and I got the
partners at home it's not bad and that
was the beginning but no it wasn't well
I'm not one of these people that wake up
it at 2 and 1/2 hours old you know I'm
gonna be an actress
you know before they even learn to feed
No well but you didn't want to do sports
but you're the biggest action hero of
all time I actually wanted to be a
veterinarian and then an interior
designer marine biologist but then I
decided acting I first started doing
special effects because I felt scared to
be an actress I felt like it's one in a
million I was actually told I was it was
easier to win the lottery then to be an
actress so I believed them but now I'm
glad I listen to myself - you're not too
long so how did the casting process were
you a part of the casting process yeah
how did it how did it all come about and
how did you both mind well of course
where she was Catholic there's no
brainer you know it was like that she's
we're lucky to get her the young girl is
a young girl
the gabrielle was hard and the shoot
there was hundreds and hundreds 100
people because there's an essence how
physically die does it look in the you
know did she play the right age and then
also be able to really bring it up cry
and to bring emotions and you know she
she got it yeah well for me I had to go
through a process it was three steps so
I did the casting director with Carla
hole and then I met with Adrian via
Skype and then I did an in-person test
with but it did feel pretty natural for
some reason I felt like you know he I
could tell he knew what he wanted and I
felt secure like okay let's do this
well you just hit it on the world it's
wouldn't it it's a natural what actors
are flowing what secure but that's
something you're really well-known for
is this it's not always about the
dialogue it's what's behind it yeah
even though Rambo has more dialogue with
these ladies in the film then he's at
all
yeah so talk a little bit about that
that sort of why why now and why was
that important well I see the majority
of the time is I'm answering questions
basically and from her that's why I said
you know it's gonna be kind of quiet
when you leave so and like they're like
my daughters and there's always
questions so I don't really have any to
say I'm responding and you know I I feel
that the relationship with her
grandmother was a whole other thing she
was kind of like like my mother like but
not you see what I mean she's like she's
like something I wish maternal you know
I mean you know you a much hole in there
I don't have you know that so it was it
was it was the perfect plant thank you
all so much and you probably got to go
method because you have so many women
around you
[Laughter]
you